[Music]
a new school year is getting underway
but that doesn't always mean children
returning to the classroom
in fact the majority of the nation's
large school districts have opted for
remote learning instead
some parents are taking things into
their own hands forming what are known
as pandemic pods they're a version of
homeschooling for small groups of
children
sometimes led by teachers or tutors but
as more companies pop up to organize
these pods a debate is brewing about
equity
meg oliver reports okay remember you can
use adding subtracting multiplying and
dividing whatever you want
all summer in this quiet backyard under
a canopy of trees
these four students have tackled math
english and social studies three days a
week
so thinking back through your entire
summer what was like the most awesome
part of it
this private education pod in larchmont
new york is just
one of many popping up across the
country ten-year-old bianca arinsibia is
going into fifth grade
it helps me because i have
much more attention than i do in regular
school
yeah and do you like coming to your pod
i don't know
when school shut down last spring
bianca's mom julia couldn't keep up with
the stressful demands of remote learning
with three kids
i found it really challenging to go from
physics with the older one
to you know tapping out sounds to learn
how to read for the kindergartner it was
two very different sets of skills did
you feel like you were treading water at
times that's how i felt the whole time
she turned to schoolhouse a service that
matches families with teachers for
in-home
education i think it's safe to say we
hit our five-year business goals in
about five months
co-founder joseph connor launched the
company in january
with eight students in a pod the cost is
about fourteen thousand dollars per
child
per year how is this different than
homeschooling so it's different because
we provide professional teachers we
recruit them from
all over the country a lot of them come
from private and charter schools
generally our teachers can make anywhere
from 10 to 20 percent more than what the
local
average salary is it's an attractive
model for parents but one that could
lead to fewer
students in local school districts and
less funding for the children
left behind our schools are more diverse
than they have ever been
but they're still segregated our pods
have an opportunity unfortunately to
become even more segregated
larue louis mccoy is a new york
university sociologist who studies
educational inequality
he worries about vulnerable communities
including the estimated 17
million kids without high-speed internet
access
at home the families that have more
money are actually creating
boutique almost private school
environments for their children
the danger in that is that as these
children move far
ahead that many of their classmates and
many of the people who will later be
comparing them to as they apply to
college
their life looks very different it's
something entrepreneur kate hahn says
is on her mind we have no interest in
taking funding away from schools
we want to work with them and in fact
we've reached out to a number of schools
in my local school district for example
han and doug
shachtel both co-founders of pricing new
york private schools
teamed up for a company called learning
pods over the summer we decided
you know we need to have a way to bring
joy to kids so the idea of
having summer pods where you have a
small group of kids
meeting with camp counselor who brings
curriculum with them
and they meet in a family's backyard and
that was really successful
the company kicks off its fall program
later this month
parents of kids in kindergarten through
fourth grade can expect to pay around 15
thousand dollars for the academic year
how are you looking to make this
affordable for everybody so a part of
every tuition
goes towards financial aid in addition
we're working with foundations
to end personal donations to feed
that same financial aid fund a good
start but not enough to go around for
the many children in need says lewis
mccoy the magnitude
of disadvantage that public schools deal
with cannot be
compensated for with private partnership
families have to do things sometimes
like reach across
socioeconomic lines you may have to
cross a neighborhood
you may have to talk to a family that
you haven't spoken to before but if you
do that work we begin the process of
inclusion
do you feel like this could be the wave
of the future as we
you know try to navigate through this
pandemic absolutely
so we really think that this is not just
a solution for the present we think that
this is the best way
for teachers to teach and students to
learn we're also working with
some philanthropic groups to make sure
that we have sponsor pods
and we're actually also trying to work
with some state governments on offering
these pods through government programs
a complex problem that many parents are
thinking about
including julia aaron sebia i think it's
a horrible situation i wish it weren't
the case
and i think that you know at the end of
the day i need to
do whatever i can for my children and
frankly if i can keep my children at
grade level
then they won't need services that can
go to another child so by taking care of
my children and their needs in some ways
it's helping everybody
for cbs this morning saturday mega
oliver larchmont
new york one of the two million issues
created by coronavirus in schools and
we've talked about this
as parents about how each district is
handing things differently
it's tough yeah and i understand you
want to do everything you can for your
child
but that economic divide just hits me in
a way that's right
so unfair right the appeal is definitely
there as a parent you can understand the
need
and the desire to do this but fourteen
thousand dollars that just seems
incredibly out of reach for so many
people
and again the have nots even less have
even less right now during the pandemic